c'est non non l'audience est reprise je
vous rappelle que daniel cohn bendit est
inculpé de d'insultés daltoniens puisque
il là il est passé de dany le rouge à
dany le vert est également d'attentats
aux moeurs puisqu'il veut changer la
société
nous avons entendu tous les témoignages
nous allons maintenant savoir ce que la
société justement reproche à daniel cohn
bendit par la bouche que dis-je la
bouche
l'orifice monstrueux de son représentant
j'ai nommé monsieur le procureur général
des proches de la république française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françaises français belges belle
monsieur le président d'opérette c3 mais
ridicule plein d'imagés rêviez crise
marienneau cher vieux débris lamentable
du barreau vermoulu de d'obédience
iberia gueule ça te manquer aujourd'hui
pauvre conne en question avait dit je le
parlais s'appelait pas comme vous
remettez daniel fait appel
pauvre conne
c'est janet mesdames et messieurs les
jurés public chéri mon amour
je n'ai rien contre les routes
encore que je préfère les rouquins
breton qui pue la moule
or aucun juif allemand qui pullulent
abiet d'ailleurs comme disait à peu près
himmler qu'on puisse être à la fois juif
et allemands ça me dépasse c'est vrai
faut savoir choisir son camp enfin
mesdames et messieurs tout ça c'est du
passé l'antisémitisme n'existe plus si
bas je veux dire que de nos jours quand
même on peut dire qu'il y à moins d'
antisémite en france que de juifs
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs personnellement je m'en fous
je suis ni l'un ni l'autre
j'ai mes papiers chrétiens de gauche il
voulait j'imagine mon certificat de
baptême
là j'ai mon bulletin d'abonnement à
télérama d'ailleurs j'en profite pour le
souligner aux auditeurs qui sont abonnés
à télé7jours télérama c'est vachement
bien aussi mais revenons-en si vous le
voulez bien mesdames et messieurs les
jurés au cas douloureux de cet ancien
combattant rondouillard qui soupire sur
ses souvenirs de guerre en faisant
pousser des laitues dans la banlieue de
francfort à moins que j'ai mal compris
le chef d'accusation ce médecin
qui êtes-vous pauvre conne qui est
daniel qui est daniel cohn bendit
j'ai posé la question à quelqu'un pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière face à
la mer je regardais mourir l'été duo de
la superbe terrasse de la somptueuse
villa balnéaire dans l'immense fortune
de ma famille me permet de jouir à mais
très nombreux moments perdus grotesque
et désoeuvrés les congés payés que la
potée misérablement un métier tristement
boudinée dans leur triste cash bonbons
trop large du catalogue des 3 suisses
je songeais tristement monsieur le
président que parmi ces mornes
quadragénaire prématurément usé par les
tracasseries bureaucratiques drogué de
télévision boursouflé de vinasse est
sursaturé de ragoût navrant
certains puis à faire la guerre sur les
barricades et émouvante d'un printemps
de fureur juvénile de fureur je vais me
tournant alors vers la jeune fille d'un
de mes amis ne purent adolescente de 15
ans de celle dont on se dit ah mon dieu
qu'est la femme est belle au sortir de
l'enfance seigneur jésus t'as vu c'est
le lot
me tournant donc vers cette frêle naïade
qui rêvasse est près de moi sur un
transat
en parcourant la rubrique des ovaires
anxieux dans cosmopolitan je lui dis je
lui dit à peu près ceci dit moi ma
petite marie c'est très bien dis moi ma
petite marie s'est tue qui et daniel
cohn bendit
daniel cohn bendit c'est pas la fille du
groupe téléphone et oui et oui mon vieux
président eh oui mon pauvre baveux
péninsulaire et oui ma pauvre jeannette
et oui mesdames et messieurs les jurés
de carnaval il faut vous y faire pour
cette génération pétain cohn bendit ou
yves montand c'est le passé vont rester
à regarder de plus près quelles
différences y at-il vraiment entre
pétain et yves montand à la réfection il
y en a une
pétain lui au moins il ferme sa gueule
il donne pas son avis sur la pologne
quand on lui demande de chanter les
feuilles mans à les feuilles mortes
monsieur président très vert en ce temps
là la vie était plus belle et l'algérie
plus française qu'aujourd'hui
et maintenant tout est changé tout fout
l'camp et daniel cohn bendit
insidieusement sans qu'ils s'en rendent
bien compte encore daniel cohn bendit
commence à perdre ses illusions et ses
cheveux rouges
vous connaissez la mouture la moumoute
jean-edern hallier à vous devriez
essayer la moumoute jean-edern hallier
connaissez pas la moutte elle s'appelle
comme ça c'est pas lui qui l'a fait
s'appelle moudjahidins alliés parce
qu'elle s'enlève tout seul oui mesdames
et messieurs les jurés
malgré la raideur et la dureté du coeur
des reins qui frétille sous la robe
austère de la justice je vous
demanderais d'avoir quelque indulgence
pour cet ancien poilu des tranchées de
la rue saint-jacques devenu presque
important
regardez là mesdames et messieurs les
jurés qui pourrait pas vouloir à ce
misérable déchets humains qui
croupissent en grâce au banc de
l'infamie
tandis que les enfants des disciples de
dany le rouge se peignent les cheveux en
vert pour aller pétarader angles en
bande sur les vélomoteurs imbécile de
leur printemps petit bourgeois cet homme
mesdames et messieurs est à l'automne de
sa vie
à la fin de son voyage il est bon pour
l'euthanasie
s'étiole sera corps ni comme la première
feuille morte que foulent aux pieds les
amants séparés qui se repoussent au bois
de vincennes et qui s'attire du bois de
boulogne
de plus de plus c'est un aliéné mental
comme la plupart des marginaux qui ont
préféré la vie communautaire au lion ce
club et qui vivent et qui vivent leur
mouvement alternatif sans le courant
continu cet être mesdames et messieurs
les jurés est à l'évidence à la fois
psychotique et névrosé comme aurait dû
le démontrer tout à l'heure notre
excellente ami le docteur folie et comme
elle ne l'a pas fait car en vérité je
vous le dis monsieur le président elles
sont toutes folles de ce voyou apatrides
dans le regard pétillant duquel elle
croit lire une étrange beauté intérieure
alors qu'il s'y cachent en réalité cet
éclair glauque de luxure concupiscente
propre immigrés satanique qui viennent
jusque dans nos bras pour culbuter nos
filles et nos compagnes
[Applaudissements]
oui ma petite folle est oui cet homme
qui mange le scinder française est à la
fois il est à la fois psychotique et
névrosé à l'intention des imbéciles et
des électeurs de gauche qui nous
écoutent par millions je rappelle la
différence fondamentale qui existe entre
un psychotique et un névrosé le
psychotique pense que deux et deux font
5 et il en est absolument ravie alors
que le névrosé lui c'est que deux et
deux font quatre
et il en est désespérée c'est pas de moi
une défense d'une discussion qui vaut ce
qu'elle vaut
je ne sais plus y aller 2-2 sigmund
freud ou de maître capello en tout cas
c'est un pyromane en 68 paranoïaque
depuis l'enfance daniel cohn bendit
semble avoir définitivement sombrer
aujourd'hui dans la pluri gami poli
philanthropique pluri gamme à ne pas
confondre avec la bigamie
schizophrénique dont souffre m rigaux
comme son nom l indique là mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
la bigamie non non ce que tu sais bien
le bigame schizophrénique joue du piano
à demain avec un entonnoir sur la tête
le 25 mai 68 sur arrêté ministériel du
regretté christian fouchet jeudi
regretter parce qu'il est mort sans me
voir en dumont peigne
daniel cohn bendit était refoulé à
forbach alors qu'il tentait de rentrer
en france pour faire encore l'andouille
avec des boutonneux sur des bouts de
bois et les pavés je propose mesdames et
messieurs les jurés pour finir que nous
le condamnons aujourd'hui à la même
peine allez vous-en cohn-bendit aller
méditer sur vos crimes en basse moselle
et rester ici car après tout mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
je vous le demande en votre âme et
conscience ne vaut-il pas mieux être
dévoré de remords dans la forêt de
forbach que dévorer de mort bac dans la
forêt francfort c'est non non
[Musique]